can we have kids and just tell these
better
do you hate people that go I don't like
fantasy I don't watch that because it's
like no no because it's no I get angry I
don't like I think I was on the
receiving end to bring it back to me
yeah yeah I was on the receiving end of
so much animosity after hitting such
great peaks that it put me through this
wringer of like it made me appreciate
like not judging our guests in artistry
I don't do it I know I was a hypocrite
before I used to do the same thing oh
this guy sucks he's but we're all in a
process we're all growing we're all
evolving and Wow hopefully putting that
back into our so they brought that up
because um and I'm not gonna say I don't
know what it is but there is love love
but there is a shift
you've always always liked you I've
never been like a [ __ ] back I loved I've
always loved you we've you've always
been fair to me very nice he's always
got a really yeah yeah but there has
been in the last I think year maybe yeah
year where I've noticed that you've just
been oh you always been nice but like
there's a shift in your approach and up
to people and your shift in your your
smiling and just you know a little bit
softer than I've ever seen you right I
used to come in hot-hot you came out and
you and I and I would come in hug - if I
were you I mean I sometimes I come in
hot but um but there is something that
happened what is it did you have like a
revelation or because something happened
yeah I mean listen though this is my
29th year for me how long you been in 23
okay so 29 years doing stand-up comedy
and you got to realize I gonna it's it's
a lot but to put it in the simplest
three acts was like the first act of my
career from 90 when I started all the
way up to you know 2001 was just
struggling trying to make ends meet it
appeared when comedy was oversaturated
Comedy Central had destroyed comedy with
too many shitty comics that they're
putting on and then the comedy albums
were dead it was literally a dead form
it was dead you couldn't get a comedy
record deal because why there there's no
need
it was a promotional item is what they
called it at Comedy Central so I finally
break through
and I breakthrough at a time when even
though I've been working hard I'm not
quite ready for everything that's about
to happen cuz I'm a kid yeah and my ego
and vanity and all the stuff that are of
alpha men coupled with I'm a deeply
insecure person
now you probably wouldn't sit here and
say like oh I I see that cuz I don't
wear it on my sleeve I see it but I
wasn't the football dude
yeah I was the quietest kid in school
yeah yeah yeah and so I'm becoming this
known entity frat kind of comic or
whatever the label was but off stage I
was more low-key so when people saw me
coming into those environments I came
across probably a fault of my own as
being a little bit like standoffish but
it was just more my own insecurities
that was keeping me from ingratiating
myself yeah but it happened and the
lasted to the third act the last ten
years it's like everything happen with
my parents I lost you know my mom and
dad same year all the stuff with my
brother all the stuff with backlash and
it just kind of humbles you in a way
that you finally have perspective and I
didn't have the perspective until really
the last many many years yeah I do
remember going to the Grove watts and
seeing you you went and your parents
mm-hmm I really did yeah and I remember
sitting I didn't even say hi I don't
think you know I think I was at the
Grove only time I think they were ever
together out here at the Grove yeah well
visit me yeah and I saw you guys in the
Grove and you had your arms around I'm
gonna get emotional I don't know why but
you guys had you had your arms around
both of them and I remember thinking oh
what a great family you know I mean and
then I found out they didn't have you
know it was like really I'm sorry man
yeah yeah it was it was an impossible
time that's the only way I describe it
it was impossible to deal with losing my
best friend my mom yeah and then a week
after my mom passes away a week my dad
comes to me and he's like I have cancer
and I have six months to live so nine
months both parents gone oh my god yeah
what do you do how do you I just went to
work man I just honestly I went to work
the one thing that they raised me to do
was follow my dream of being a performer
so I felt like they could vicariously
still be living through me by me
succeeding more
that was also another big catalyst when
my mom was sick I accomplished so much
in those couple years because I wanted
to show her every [ __ ] thing
so SNL all that stuff came from me
telling her I'm gonna do all this stuff
and kind of the pressure of feeling like
I was keeping her alive because her
immune system is good because she's
happy and seeing her son reveling in
this excitement so weirdly I felt like
the prognosis for health with my mom was
like just keep doing stuff keep showing
her more social stick around
yeah about that I think that is what
keeps people around longer and that
feeling of excitement and looking ahead
and knowing that you it's a day we say
that even with you know terminal
patients they last longer when they're
happy and you probably gave her extra
time because you made her happy
yes she did she stayed alive longer than
what they anticipated so so yeah I mean
the last like a bunch of years and again
I think you and I have always had a for
whatever reason we've always had had a
an easier quicker connection yeah than
some of the other people that we could
name names or not yeah it may have felt
like I was a little prickly and and so I
always appreciated that yeah yeah
[Music]